se
[Aplausos]
você se sente o tempo todo ansioso
cansado dessa conexão 1 milhão de fontes
de informação que chegam nos alcançam a
cada momento através do nosso celular
através das redes sociais
E como você sente
se você se sente tranquilo tá em plena
conexão
consegue se concentrar com o seu
interior consegue manter o seu espírito
elevado mesmo no momento como esse em
que a gente tá o tempo todo demandado e
com tanta energia ao nosso redor através
dos meios digitais nos digitais como
você se sente
o tio me sinto desafiado me sinta
desafiado e eu quero dar o exemplo do
meu aniversário foi recentemente Já
pensaram já já perceberam como fazer
aniversário a gente ficou difícil a
gente recebi tantas mensagens e
múltiplos formatos de gente que quer o
nosso bem
são emojis são mensais e redes sociais e
aí não basta ter uma tem que ter várias
né então é é LinkedIn Instagram é o
WhatsApp é Facebook
todas as redes todo mundo tem não te
desejar uma mensagem bacana e você
naquele seu dia tentando curtir eu mesmo
tempo sentindo preso pela necessidade de
responder E demonstrar aquelas pessoas
que você tem essa conexão com elas
Tá bom eu não sei se você se sente
ansioso que você sente
tá tranquilo
e eu só quero dizer que a hiperconexão
veio para ficar e ela vai aumentar
Acredite ela vai aumentar e a gente tem
que tá preparado para isso por outro
lado essa questão uma questão incrível e
eu não sei se você já parou para
refletir com bacana é a gente viver
nesse mundo que vivemos hoje que
oportunidade temos
eu vou dar três exemplos de Três
Gerações diferentes porque o mundo mudou
muito rapidamente ao longo dessas Três
Gerações
eu queria começar com a história do meu
avô Antônio Mauro Antônio nasceu em
Portugal na ser uma vida interior de
Portugal era casado com a minha avó Rosa
ambos já são falecidos e tiveram alguns
filhos dois em Portugal e dois no Brasil
o primeiro Deus meu pai no Brasil pois
bem meu avô durante a segunda guerra
mundial saiu de Portugal buscando
melhores condições de vida e veio com
imigrantes no Brasil deixou a família em
Portugal
e ficou alguns anos aqui estabelecendo
uma condição a montando o seu pequeno
negócio numa cidade que começou a ferver
e hoje eu vou falar sobre ela mas um
pouco e deixou sua esposa e dois filhos
em Portugal por anos foi buscar luz
quando acabou a guerra para traseiro do
Brasil
e Já pensaram como seria hoje em dia
ficamos anos somente podemos conectar
com as pessoas que amamos buscando bem
para nossa família através de cartas
e sem saber se nossos filhos cresceram
se Estão bem estão doentes Como estão
voltar depois de muito tempo quase como
refugiada de guerra que na prática foi
um pouco de aconteceu e ver seus filhos
maiores sem saber daquele dia a dia do
pequeno cotidiana
Ah pois bem Hoje é impensável a gente
aqui na academia às vezes fica durante
dias em casa ansioso imagine anos tem
essa conexão tão primordial
por outro lado eu mesmo posso falar da
minha experiência geracional quando eu
fui estudar fora de Volta Redonda Cidade
na coluna cidade onde meu avô encontrou
seu estabelecimento e fez sua vida
acontecer e onde meu pai nasceu e hoje
se encontra eu fiz lá em Campinas
Unicamp fiquei 400km de distância da
minha casa e quando eu mudei para lá eu
morava numa república e ninguém tinha
telefone fixo era 1994 eram tempos em
que o telefone fixo era declarado no
Imposto de Renda então valioso que eram
ativo tão importante para as pessoas
para sua amiga Fiquei poucos times
privilégio
bom então eu tinha um trato com os meus
pais eu saí é para ligar para minha mãe
que fala mais preocupada comigo sem
saber como a gente tava tinha um vizinho
que dava notícia seu dono da casa de
quem alugavam mas a gente um trato e eu
tinha que ir todos os domingos em
horário à tarde específico fazer uma
ligação de um orelhão de um telefone
fixo de uma fila de estudantes
o que como ficava naquele dia que ele
então eu tivesse com frio e não tivesse
por minha preguiça deixar se meus pais
outro lado abandonados ou enfim tivesse
acontecido com imprevisto irmão imagino
como seria o coração e eu que tenho dois
filhos eu moro imagina como me sentiria
porque hoje ficar sem saber deles por
alguns instantes que seja me deixa
agoniado e até por isso eu quero
agradecer a vocês pai mãe muito obrigado
pelo amor que você se dedicaram por
permitir que eu fizesse com essa conexão
de nosso amor a carreira construir
hoje eu quero trazer vocês agora para 27
anos depois para 2021 em que essa minha
a mesma mãe fala com seus netos que
moram em outro continente onde meu irmão
reside todos os dias conta histórias de
ninar para que netos possam dormir
usando de videoconferência na palma da
sua mão e o maior desafio que ela tem e
ela me confessa e sorrindo é que ela vai
inventando as histórias e eles acabam às
vezes adormecendo e quando adormecem o
que acontece é que no dia seguinte eles
lembram da história e ela muitas vezes
não lembro de onde parou e ela tem que
reconstruir na sua memória aquela
lembrança que para os meta era tão
querida porque para eles o virtual e o
físico era uma mesma conexão fluente
bom então faça reflexão olhem o quanto
ao longo de Três Gerações a nossa vida
mudou e eu não consigo achar que isso é
para pior eu consigo somente achar que
isso é uma grande oportunidade da gente
continuar evoluindo e crescendo e quer
sair ter conexão vai trazer para gente
grande possibilidade daqui por diante
falando de interconexão eu queria
retomar aqui o significado dessa palavra
conexão significa ligação significa
União significa vínculo hiper é sobre em
cima então hiperconexão é muito vínculo
muito União muita conexão e por outro
lado desconexão é quando a gente não tem
isso ou seja quando estamos fazendo algo
que a gente não coloca nossa alma também
tomando alguma atitude alguma
Providência ou envolvidos com algo em
que não estamos dando a melhor versão de
nós mesmos
É nesse mundo cada vez mais
hiperconectado e na sociedade em que
cada vez mais vemos pessoas que estão
passando por esse processo de desconexão
é muito importante que a gente tente
retomar a essência daquilo que nos faz
humanos
desde que nós fomos concebidos como
embriões dentro do útero qualquer um de
nós
e a gente começa a nossa existência
conectado
e a nossa essência passa por uma conexão
física que a conexão da placenta a
conexão do útero que ela conexão
tangível e por uma conexão emocional
positiva ou negativa cada pessoa terá
sua história mais uma conexão que nos
vincula desde que somos concebidos a
nossos pais em particular nossas mais e
assim vamos desenvolver Nossa trajetória
nascemos pequenos olhares pequenos
gestos mãos que se tocam
e no início um chorinho por muito
chorinho algumas fraldas E conforme
vamos evoluindo cada vez mais a extensão
que nos definem como humano passa pela
conexão as pessoas com as quais nós
somos crianças nos relacionamos vários
estudos dos principais neurocientista da
humanidade demonstram que quanto mais
uns conectamos mais interagimos mais
palavras falamos a nossa infância mais
Terra melhor vai ser a formação
substância Branca nosso neuro córtex mas
são os neurônios vão se desenvolver ou
seja está interconectado estar super
conectado está conectado e aquilo que
nos faz mais desenvolvidos mais
potencialmente capazes de transformar o
mundo para melhor e deixar aqui um bom
legado
o E conforme vamos crescendo as conexões
como adolescentes os grupos sociais que
nos definem que depois vão ser
refletidos nossa vida adulta os grupos
profissionais os grupos voluntários
países cidades
economias
empresas tudo isso são conexões
e É por essas conexões e analogamente
estamos ensinando as máquinas a pensar
e quando vejo meus filhos se
desenvolvendo próxima é muito parecido
com o processo das máquinas os bebês vão
tentando vão errando vão observando e a
gente quer pai e mãe quando menos espera
de repente ouvi do outro lado e percebe
a construção uma conexão de frases ou
enfim de conceitos que a gente nem sabe
de onde surgiram não é quem já vivenciou
a experiência sabe o que eu tô falando
isso é um pouco ficou umas máquinas
também tô aprendendo outra vez processo
que a gente mude machine learning e que
vai levar a hiperconexão e através da
tecnologia à espera de dimensões que a
gente está começando a entender sobre as
quais eu vou falar em breve mas que a
gente ainda não sabe onde vai vamos
levar eu só tenho uma certeza
e tem que ser para um lugar melhor de
onde estamos porque ela não todo
desenvolvimento da humanidade a conexão
o desenvolvimento veio por esse vínculo
por essa integração por esse
hipervinculo hiper União essa aí pela
união que não se as formas a
interconexão na qual nós estamos na
iminência eminência hiperconexão ela que
vai fazer a transformação da humanidade
agora no salto cada vez mais caótico
hoje nós vamos falar agora do Século 21
nós estamos no início da revolução na
nova revolução da revolução digital no
mundo 4.0 do mundo hiperconectado dos
carros autônomos da sociedade cada vez
mais integrada das redes que cada vez
vai se conectam e se interagem edifícios
que são inteligentes e da cidade cada
vez mais geram vida própria e de um novo
mundo que vai nos levar uma dimensão que
a gente ainda não consegue entender
direito
e para saímos o2g a pouco mais de 20
anos em que a gente mal usava o vô a voz
através de meios remotos e hoje estamos
falando
atrasados nosso país do 5g quer para
muitas redes a maioria delas
Tecnicamente cem vezes mais rápido
entendo de transmissão de dados de
informação entre pessoas entre empresas
e entre organizações sem vezes mais
rápido que o 4G e na Coreia do Sul
enquanto nós falamos na China enquanto
as falam já estão testando até 16g nas
candina gen a gente dia vai ser 50 vezes
mais rápida do que o 5g ou seja elas não
fazem alguns poucos anos de um mundo que
vai ter uma possibilidade de transmissão
de dados 5.000 cinco mil vezes mais
rápidas do que hoje
e isso vai transformar radicalmente a
forma como a gente entende a maneira de
fazer negócio vai transformar a saúde a
telemedicina haverá uma realidade cada
vez maior você vai ter pessoas que são
especialistas em um país podendo operar
pessoas em outros locais você vai ter
educação transformada você não precisa
mais ir hoje já numa biblioteca para
buscar conhecimento Imagine quando eu
tiver a velocidade tão grande
conhecimento você poder interagir com
múltiplos especialistas em rede em tempo
real
você vai ter um mundo em que a
computação quântica vai possibilitar que
a gente trouxesse uma transação a
velocidade da luz
Olá tudo vai ser muito transformado os
nossos filhos a próxima geração Mas se a
geração game ficada vai ser uma geração
e que vai ter dificuldade vai haver uma
dificuldade muito grande se perceber o
que é o mundo digital e o que é o mundo
físico que eles vão tá integrado uma
realidade cada vez mais phygital físico
com digital
Oi e aí aonde essa hiperconexão vai nos
levar final aonde todo esse Progresso
vai nos levar
Será que a gente se conectando com as
pessoas que realmente importam Será que
todo esse Progresso tem nos trazido
felicidade Será que a gente tem usado
essa tecnologia em prol daquilo que nos
beneficia é que nos faz melhores
e eu vejo muita gente que tá trazendo os
relacionamentos nas suas conexões igual
a velocidade recente daquela rede que
todo mundo usa que agora você pode ouvir
um áudio em uma vez e meio em duas vezes
parece que a gente faz relacionamento em
duas vezes então ele quer falar com as
pessoas e que aquelas responda muito
rápido interagem um com o mínimo
possível não nos liguem e tudo em modo
assíncrono não modo síncrono
ou será que a gente tá aproveitando a
tecnologia e tudo que ela nos traz que
eu acabei de sempre ficar na história da
minha família em prol daquilo que nos
beneficia Será que eu mesmo consigo
fazer isso da melhor forma
pois bem eu fui buscar uma referência
para poder tentar entender esse um pouco
melhor e encontrei uma referência no
livro antes de partir da Bruna e o ar
que a mãe fez meio australiana também
temos Trabalho maravilhoso lá na Cláudia
Quintana Arantes aqui no Brasil de
pessoas que estudaram profundamente os
arrependimentos que aqueles que partiram
se conectaram com outro plano se
conectar o do nosso levaram consigo e
tem cinco principais causas de
arrependimento
em todas essas causas tem a ver com a
desconexão daquilo ou com aquilo que
realmente nos importa o outro amar e ser
amado tá com amigos Vencerá mais esses
bons momentos tem mais tempo de
qualidade conexões de qualidade
bom então
e eu recomendo é cada vez mais a gente
também mantenha para que possamos ter
esse equilíbrio de em pleno século 21 em
plena e Tecnologia em um mundo cada vez
mais acelerado essa conexão com algo
superior algo mais espiritual seja
através do mais e fornece seja através
de qualquer prática que te faça bem não
importa não é uma questão religiosa
ainda que a religião seja importante
para aqueles que têm é muito importante
que ele também se conecta que você é
algo maior para que a gente possa usar
essas possibilidades essa aí pé
tecnologia tudo que nós temos falado e
vice e vamos vivenciar na prática
em prol do nosso bem e para o bem do
outro
que eu mais vejo a gente que tem medo da
interconexão nós não devemos temer a
hiperconexão
E desde que nascemos nós estamos
conectados todo o desenvolvimento social
vem pela conexão nós temos que ter medo
da desconexão a desconexão traz um mundo
que não existe empatia não existe
sentimento não existe se colocar no
lugar do outro traz um mundo e que a
guerras traz um mundo que a fome traz um
mundo em que a miséria traz um mundo que
nos faz mais tristes mais infelizes
Porque somente estão desconectados é que
podemos de fato não nos importar com
tudo isso e usar a tecnologia que nos
conecta para fazer desse mundo um lugar
melhor
e eu tenho medo da desconexão não dá
hiperconexão aí da conexão pode fazer
novas formas de amar e ser amados vamos
fazer novas formas de se conectar com
pessoas que estão próximas ou distantes
pode nos trazer novas possibilidades nos
conectar com sentimentos que nos fazem
bem vai trazer nosso possibilidades
econômicas para multiplicar a riqueza e
fazer com que mais gente conectada a
escala vivam num mundo melhor aí para
conexão eu tenho certeza vai nos trazer
soluções tecnológicas para que a gente
resolva os grandes dilemas da humanidade
vamos questões ecológicas como as
questões sociais como as questões
sanitárias tão premente que agora nos
afligem a todos
a Timon a desconexão
abracem a hiperconexão a tecnologia vai
possibilitar que a gente transforme o
mundo numa escala jamais vista no poder
jamais dado a nós humanos de fazer o bem
e tem um impacto real na sociedade
E aí per conexão vai resgatar a essência
do humanismo
e Eu repito a hiperconexão vai resgatar
a essência do humanismo
Oi e para encerrar eu não queria deixar
de fazer aqui uma última fala essa
singela bom aqui é uma homenagem a meu
avô outro avô não aquele queria de
Portugal meu avô capixaba que há dez
anos se conectar desse plano e partir
para novas jornadas em outras conexões
que tanto me ensinou e tá sempre
hiperconectado aqui comigo em sentimento
em coração e deixou muitas dessas
mensagens de otimismo e esperança que eu
quero trazer pra vocês Muito obrigado
E aí